[Music]
soil health you know isn't just one
thing it's like a system it's approach I
mean for us it's combining no-till crop
rotation cover crops and then planting
like native grass species and our
sensitive areas and our wetlands and our
salinity areas and along our watersheds
to try to make our land not only
profitable but sustainable for the
future it's a way to pull carbon out of
the air and put it in the ground and
[Music]
carbon them organic matter are basically
the same thing so if I can pull carbon
out of the air and put it in the ground
I'll make it to soil healthier we're not
seeing the salt issues as bad we're also
not seeing the mud when we go into plant
do you take care of the soil it'll take
care of you building a resilient soil if
it's wet if it's dry if it's cold if
it's hot I want a soil that protects me
with in those situations or is able to
handle those situations without costing
me a crop there's so many living things
there and when you go out there and dig
when it with the living cover it just
looks alive you're going to save money
on fuel you're gonna save money with the
fertilizer cuz that's staying where you
put it long run you're gaining yield
because you're increasing the value of
land it also helped our our workload
issues it allowed a better quality of
life for me and my family and as it
turns out it's a better quality of life
for the soil it's better for the cows as
well diversity is always improves the
biological health and actually cattle
prefer diversity rather than
monocultures we've made a real push to
involve our land owners on the on the
land that we rent and leased to to get
involved in to understand what we're
doing we have a pretty good crop
rotation that we're happy with we're
trying to have the soil covered pretty
much all the time
feeding the soils and
carbon dioxide out of the air through
photosynthesis and feeding soil
microbiology increasing our soil organic
matter
it is accepting the responsibility to
continue to spread the word and to share
the things that you've learned over the
years share the the knowledge the
successes the failures of what it's all
about it's about leaving it better than
you found it
long term my kids talk about farming
they they love being out here you know
on AI that's up to each one of them if
they want to do this or not
I hope one or two of them decided to
come back and run the farm
you